si parece que Wall Street ha conseguido
espantar esos fantasmas que surgieron el
viernes pasado cuando el gobierno tuvo
que intervenir en silicon Valley Bank
esta mañana a primera hora la bolsa
habría en números positivos los bancos
regionales parece que remontaban después
de los últimos días que han sido
bastante complicados números verdes en
la bolsa por fin parece que el mensaje
de ayer a primera hora de la mañana del
presidente Joe biden Y esa
estabilización que parece que estamos
recibiendo de la inflación han ayudado
en el mes de enero la inflación rozaba
los
6,4% y ahora mismo en el mes de febrero
Perdón ha bajado a un 6% algo pues que
ha dado una cierta confianza entre los
usuarios y entre los inversionistas
también hemos visto también en números
verdes esta mañana y repuntando no
solamente esos bancos regionales que
estaban más amenazados también el s p500
el nasdaq y el dow Jones los principales
indicadores de la bolsa de Wall Street
que van hacia arriba En un alza pero muy
pendientes todos Eso sí de la decisión
que tome la semana que viene el Banco
Central estadounidense porque estaba
previsto que se reuniera para el día 22
para decidir si aumentará o no Si
continuará aumentando o no los tipos de
interés en principio el rumor era que
iba a ser así pero después de lo
ocurrido ahora los economistas y los
expertos apuntan a que seguramente la
Fed no va a mantener esa subida de los
tipos de interés no va a subirlos más Y
va y va a intentar apostar por recuperar
la confianza de los inversores y de la
ciudadanía antes que luchar contra la
inflación Porque ahora mismo eso es lo
que más preocupa recuperar la confianza
por parte de los inversores para
recuperar esa estabilidad esta
estabilidad sobre todo en Los pequeños y
en los medianos bancos que han sido los
que más afectados se han visto en el
punto de mira y que esta mañana vuelven
a recuperar fuerza pero todavía estamos
muy pendientes de ver cómo avanza la
jornada